of armin laschet 25 121 voix contre 466
c'est sur ce score serré carmine
l'achète est devenu le nouveau leader de
la cd où le parti chrétien démocrate au
pouvoir depuis 2005
dans son premier discours il a rendu un
hommage appuyé à la chancelière
skip fils il y a beaucoup de gens qui
pensent qu'en gala merkel est bonne et
compétent klamath groupe féminin vient
ensuite lancé des youyous la réputation
de la chancelière parmi les gens d'ici
et à l'étranger peut se résumer en un
mot ammann façon en confiance dix femmes
nous avons maintenant besoin de cette
confiance en tant que parti et cette
confiance n'est pas un don ou un
héritage n'est pas quelque chose que
vous pouvez simplement transmettre 10
vous devez travailler pour cette
confiance à en battre européen convaincu
armin laschet tu était jusque là
président de la rhénanie du
nord-westphalie l'une des régions les
plus riches d'allemagne modéré il a
toujours soutenu la politique centriste
d'angela merkel notamment sur
l'immigration
une position contestée au sein de la cd
ou et par son rival battu friedrich
mertz qui a fait campagne sur la
droitisation du parti m dames 10 pendant
et mousse puis l'a1 est content le parti
doit à nouveau être un parti sans les
incertitudes de l'état constitutionnelle
d'allemagne
ce qui signifie également qu'il doit
mieux contrôler l'immigration vers notre
pays où d'un contrôle de l'intégrité
territoriale de notre pays doit en fin
de compte est également garanti par la
protection des frontières extérieures
une si les frontières européennes
n'offre pas une protection suffisante
une élection décisive pour l'avenir de
l'allemagne avec les élections
législatives prévues fin septembre
rien n'est cependant gagné pour armin
laschet tu selon un sondage récent
seulement 28% des personnes interrogées
estiment qu'il a la carrure d'un
chancelier le choix du candidat de
centre-droit pour ce scrutin se tiendra
au printemps prochain